stop trying to get good at the things
you suck at too i just i need to say
that because it's the biggest lie we've
ever been told it dings our confidence
with i still can't read if i if i wrote
you two sentences in an email half the
words would light up misspelled and some
of them are so bad that i try three
different times to spell and the
computer can't even like if i could talk
to me like idiots like what are you
trying to say i have no freaking clue
what you're saying and then i just put
like good
like
completely relationship but what it does
is let me just ask you
watching or listening right now if
you're
if you work on something you suck at
does it make you feel empowered does it
make you feel like you want to like me
trying to do accounting like you could
never do it it's not my personality so
what i know about the most successful
people on the planet including you ed
you just got really great at a few
things correct the things that light you
up the things that inspire you and when
that fire starts you can't stop it and
eventually you'll pay someone to do the
things you suck